this has to be the number one requested
game for me to review so here we go
Mass Effect so if you guys don't already
know Bioware is like the master of
making you feel like the game revolves
around the choices you make some
characters die some characters live some
hate you some love you but it all
revolves around how you play the game so
in Mass Effect you play as Commander
Shepard commander Shepards either a dude
or a chick depending on what you prefer
and you can manually adjust and modify
how Commander Shepard looks but whenever
I do that I try to make the character
look like me and they end up looking
like grand moff tarkin so I just went
with generic Commander Shepard from the
box seemed a safe way to do it and the
story of Mass Effect isn't just
worldwide it is in fact galaxy wide yeah
that's big long story short humans are
the newbies being integrated into the
Galactic government the other
civilizations that have been part of
this for like thousands of years don't
really like that that much so that
causes tension but now a Spectre which
is pretty much like Judge Dredd they
have the unbridled freedom of making a
call like executing someone if they feel
is best for the galaxy one of these
spectres has gone rogue so the council
names you the next Spectre and so you
got to take your crew and hunt his ass
down after that it is epic awesomeness
to a galactic degree the story feels
like it hangs on your every move example
you take a crew of you and a couple
people so I had a crew of three going to
talk to this guy we get to the guy we
talked to him one of my crew members
blows him away if that crew member
hadn't been in my party that guy would
have lived and actually cameoed in Mass
Effect 2 but alas I did not see him in
Mass Effect 2 because he had a hole in
his chest that's awesome I mean the main
story is going to happen regardless of
what you do you cannot avert the climax
of the game but it's cool to have
choices that you make affect things in
the game like how people view you how
people interact with you how you
interact with people don't be moments
where it'll be like oh quick make it
called we save these people are these
people and you're just like oh
those people sorry guys who lives who
dies up to you that's badass and that's
always cool to see in a game that deals
with galactic politics or politics in
general my problems with the game are
actually with some of the mechanics like
you have absolute control over your
weapon and armor mods so much so that
you have to set aside a few minutes
every time you get something new to
modify everything like you know in an
RPG where you get a new piece of armor
and you put it on your main guy then you
allocate all the rest of your armor down
the line accordingly it's kind of like
that times ten at least
I mean I like
having control of my stuff but why can't
we have just one mod that affects all
guns they may or may not have fix that
in Mass Effect 2 just saying and when
you go to a planet for a mission that's
not story beige is just a generic
mission this base is the same as the
previous base which was the same as the
previous base so on so forth it just
made it feel generic in every way a
little variety would have been awesome
more variety than just a couple of
locked doors but the money in the game
is nice it's also broken as hell I don't
know if it's a good thing or a bad thing
still but by the end of the game you max
that you are the richest thing in the
galaxy you like the Bill Gates of the
galaxy if Bill Gates had a kid with
Chuck Norris that is you in Mass Effect
one a combination that can only come
from sci-fi fantasy but all in all the
gameplays grade is called an RPG but
it's an action RPG so it's not like
turn-based or anything like that
bolts are flying you're ducking behind
boxes you're picking out you're picking
people off good stuff and the story is
really good me intensity gets a little
out of control sometimes there are some
moments where you'll be like oh my god
if I wanted to feel like this and decide
who lives and who dies I'd actually join
the military some of the choices you
have to make are a little rough but
that's what an epic game should feel
like and the choices you make in Mass
Effect one actually carry over to Mass
Effect 2 that is how a sequel should be
one word of advice when you play the
game build up your dialogue options the
games just a lot more interesting when
you have more things to say priority one
build up your dialogue priority two
weapons and so if you have an Xbox
360 or PC play Mass Effect no Mass
Effect one for ps3 right now sorry but
ps3 gets Kratos from mortal kombat so
there is that and Mass Effect two
actually just came out for the ps3 like
today so I guess you can jump on that
but I strongly recommend Mass Effect and
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more Sam Commander Shepard this is
my favorite site on the Citadel or
YouTube